This year in Britain,
the power to shape the future of our country
will rest in your hands
in the Labour Party.
We've been building to this for four years.
We're confident we have a plan
that could move our country forward,
end the cost of living crisis,
take back our streets,
get the NHS back on its feet,
cheaper energy bills for your home,
more opportunities for your children.
But most of all,
I'm ready to renew our politics
so it once again serves our country.
I know that politics isn't held in
particularly high regard in Britain,
but I've spent four years
bringing the Labour Party back to service.
And in 2024,
we can do the same for politics.
So wherever you are,
however you're celebrating,
Happy New Year.
Let's make sure this is the year where, together,
we get Britain's future back.